good morning Hank it's Tuesday Henry
requested today that I make a video
about dragons and dinosaurs where they
fight together against bad guys and
they're scary parts but not too many
scary parts and I then explained to him
that sadly I can only make videos where
my head moves around a screen but if
there are any brilliant video editor
slash motion graphics artists out there
in nerdfighteria please take this idea
and run with it so since I can't make a
video with dinosaurs and Dragons where
they fight together against bad guys I'm
gonna make a video about the future of
nerdfighteria so I get here we have this
huge nerdfighter gathering at VidCon and
we talk about what's ahead for
nerdfighter Ian I thought I'd share some
of the things that came out of that
discussion one we want to do more IRL
events Hank you're on tour right now and
you're having a great time we want to do
more of that it's a bit difficult for me
to travel right now because family but
hey we want to do more nerdfighter
gatherings that were a part of and B we
want to facilitate nerdfighter
gatherings that don't include us I mean
the Internet is great and everything but
nothing beats real life I mean except
for the internet the internet does beat
real life but real life is a close
second to heck we want to make
educational video for younger people I
don't think I'm allowed to say anything
more about that just yet but wouldn't it
be great if elementary school students
had video that got them excited about
like science and history and also gently
introduced them to the idea that dragons
and dinosaurs did not technically
coexist three non video educational
materials to go with crash course so a
crash course is used in thousands of
schools which is great and we hear from
lots of teachers and students that they
would love like essays and primary
sources and worksheets and other stuff
to go with the videos Khan Academy has
helped us out with that some link in the
doobly-doo but we'd like to do much more
of it in the coming year for decreasing
world suck and increasing world awesome
year round so like the project for
awesome is amazing last December we
raised more than eight hundred thousand
dollars for charity but we'd like to do
more of that stuff
year round speaking of which why am I
wearing a Brazil Jersey well because
with matching donations Brazil fans have
donated more than $16,000 to sarcoma
research to win my World Cup affection
and overall Hank that project is now
worth more than eighty thousand dollars
for the sarcoma foundation I mean I do
not need any more potassium today
because that is bananas anyway we want
to do more of this kind of stuff
five advertising so we've never run
pre-roll ads on vlogbrothers because we
find pre-rolls annoying instead we have
these display ads that are like here and
even dude I know I don't know I'm not
good with directions but
now that pre-roll ads are like 99% of
YouTube's revenue vlogbrothers I'm not
allowed to say actual numbers but it
could generate like five or six times
more money than it currently does so
we're wondering a if we should do that
and be how here are some options keep it
like it is
delete ads entirely from vlogbrothers
start using free rolls and donate all
the money to the foundation to decrease
worldsuck start using free rolls and put
all the money into education and
nerdfighter projects like Hank many
years ago you bought vihart a bunch of
equipment so that she could make better
videos more often that was super cool
with you but it also turned out to be
like the best $1000 you've ever spent
because my heart went on to be this
phenomenally successful educational
creator so we could use the money to do
way more stuff like that and plus fund
other nerdfighter projects or we could
do some combination thereof nerdfighters
this is something we really want to hear
from you about so there is a survey link
in the doobly-doo where you could also
talk to us about like what you'd like to
see from crash course and education
content on YouTube in general and lastly
Hank you know how we sponsored this
amazing soccer team AFC Wimbledon well
thanks to fans of the Hank game channel
we've been able to increase our
sponsorships so that next season we are
gonna be on their shorts you heard me
right Hank this design is going to be on
the shorts of the actual AFC Wimbledon
uniforms and Hank this also means that
when you play as AFC Wimbledon in FIFA
15 you will see this on their computer
shorts that's right nerdfighters we did
it we made it to FIFA so in our notice
those are some of our thoughts in the
future of nerdfighteria please let us
know where you'd like it to go in
comments dftba Hank I will see you on
Friday